can you read you the [ __ ] exchange  so i go great job he goes thank you dude  i go  that's so gross honestly just be  yourself oh my goodness no  just let me finish let me finish stop  stop this for a second right  hollywood and show business is [ __ ]  oh my god  dude these guys probably think you're  trying to [ __ ] yes  i could forget the pressure and have fun  and enjoy the experience  so he goes for sure  lol appreciate that a lot man coming  from you feels good right so he knows  you i have to i have to double down now  right  so if you have any questions mark like i  don't i don't know anything about music  i'm telling you this boy half expects to  see a dick pic next right yeah so just  send me a message i'm a comedian but i  know things oh  you said that  oh my god this is literally like you  know what they do to catch a predator  and they're reading the text that's what  it sounds like